for each function in question two and
let's pick let's pick a because we did
that one right
so the function was x squared plus three
X plus two it says use the derivative to
evaluate F and the way we read that is f
dash two so we worked out f dash X it's
right yeah okay so it's 2x plus 3
yeah so far so good so the reason why we
use this notation is because I can deal
with this just like any other function
so part one says what is f dash to okay
first let's evaluate it and they let's
think about what does that even mean
this here is f dash X so f dash two
means wherever you saw an X replace it
with our two so I'm going to write your
step ahead of me I've replaced the X for
that two that's four plus three which as
master says is seven is that okay
now what does it mean this F dash X it
tells me the gradient at any point you
like right the point they seem to be
interested in is x equals two at that
point the gradient is seven how would
you describe that visually to someone
seven gradient of seven that's a very
steep is it going up or going down up so
this is increasing yeah increasing very
steep got that in yet
part two finally y-coordinate of the
point P on this original function where
x equals two that was enough for find
the y-coordinate on this guy when x
equals two in other words part two is
asking for F of two does that make sense
y equals F of two so let's have a look
can you help me do the substitution what
am I gonna write first don't tell me the
answer I tell me the substitution two
squared three lots of two plus two very
good now we can start to evaluate four
plus six plus two last I checked that
was 12
very good okay and this is a y
coordinate right so this is not about
like how fast are you going this is
about where are you right you've got a
y-value of 12
part three find the equation of the
tangent at P okay now think about this
write this at this point it will really
help to have a very rough sketch
okay so let's draw ourselves a Cartesian
plane because we want to work out what
it is that we're calculating okay x
squared plus 3x plus 2 if I asked you to
graph that what would you do to it what
were your instinct it is a parabola but
to know what kind of problem going to
thank you you are so have a look we can
factorize this can't we X plus 2 and X
plus 1 very good
so X intercepts minus 2 and minus what
I'm gonna go through there and we
actually saw this before didn't we
he actually had a look oh yeah I'm just
looking if I'm gonna have enough space
like so is that okay I'm trying to make
sure my scales okay alright so what
they're asking for is where is the
tangent when x equals 2 that's why
they're interested in this so if that's
negative 1 and negative 2 I'm placing
two about there there's x equals 2
so here I am on the graph what would the
tangent look like can you put your arm
the way the tangent would go there we go
it's going to be kind of just sort of
going up and then just grazing it right
just touching and it off it goes so we
can in fact draw this somewhat
approximately right now like so that
green line that's what trying to find
okay part 1 and part 2 they gave us all
the information that we needed we've got
next value namely 2 we've got a y value
namely 12 so I'm gonna write them down
together 2 and 12 and using the
derivative the grading function I also
know the gradient at this point right up
there you told me before it was steep
and it was positive does that match what
you expected thumbs up so I've got M
equals 7 if these are the piece of
information that I've got how do I find
the equation of a line that goes through
there with this gradient what am I gonna
use I've got a form of a straight line
for this right this green things a
straight line I'll give you a clue it
starts with Y minus y minus y1 what's y1
in this case it's 12 it's a y-coordinate
Y minus y1 there it is and then equals
what M which is the gradient 7 outside
of X minus x1 which in this case is 2
like so can we tidy this up a little bit
let's tie this up I'm gonna add 12 to
both sides and expand this what am I
gonna get done in 7 X minus minus minus
2 now you can see my graph is not all
that accurate it should have been
steeper actually because it should have
gone through it - - but not too bad I
just eyeballed it ok so now that you
know what it is you can draw a much more
accurate version of it 7x minus 2 is the
equation of this green line you've used
calculus to be able to find where
exactly this is not an approximation not
like it's kind of yeah
yep yes no yes yes cool okay very good
so we worked out the grainy and the
tension here and then we're pieced it
together with either information to get
the equation the entire thing about the
tangent
is it messy sorry sorry I'm just can't
write straight that's all Baker
negative sir I'm gonna improve my
drawing now a little bit
it shouldn't cut there it should
actually cut more like there no yeah
yeah I got it okay so and in fact if you
want we can just check this real quick
well let's have a look okay
I'm too lazy to plug it in so I'm just
gonna draw this for you right now so
what do we got x squared plus 3 X plus 2
right
plus 2 so there's my graph and what do
we work out as the equation of the
tangent 7 X 7 X minus 2 oops
go away there it is right there nailed
it see that it's not close its exact
that's the art of this that we've got
precision not like I'm kind of close
I've got an approximation we have it
precisely and in fact the further you
zoom into that it never cuts twice it
only ever it's a kind of it actually
does touch which asymptotes don't do
okay